cons are incredible there's one thing I
will say because I told Michelle my
friend Michelle
uh her and Chris they just they lost
their their boy Preston who was a good
buddy of mine he was 16 to horrible
cancer and I you know he was Ronald you
know went to the Ronald McDonald house
and they helped him and he went through
I don't know how many surgeries I sat
with this kid through chemo visited him
in the hospital I FaceTime with all my
superhero friends like Zach Levi and
Welling and all these guys and
great kid I used to drive up to Hemet to
see him and his family and we'd watched
in fact his favorite show was Teen Wolf
and if he knew I was talking to you
right now I wish he I wish he would go
crazy in fact his mom we were texting
and she's like oh my God and she's like
it's hard for me to even watch that show
because and and when it ended Preston
was so upset he was so upset and
downstairs here
I go what's your favorite show
and he goes Teen Wolf and I go
Teen Wolf
really
I hadn't seen Teen Wolf and he goes yeah
can we watch it and I go
yeah let's watch Teen Wolf we ended up
watching like three episodes of the
first season and I was like this is fun
this is kind of fun and he knew that he
knew like some of the lines and but it's
amazing and what I felt like when I go
to these cons you know for Smallville or
anything I've done when when you could
see like hey this was a mo this was
something my dad and I had on Tuesday
nights or this is and it means so much
to people and you don't realize you're
like that's just a show how could this
mean something and so how does that make
you feel how do you how do you deal with
that stuff
uh
I mean you feel awesome especially like
I was I hope in my life I get to do more
but like you mentioned a film I did with
Sigourney called prayers for Bobby now
that movie is based on a true story
about a young boy Bobby Griffith who who
sadly kills himself
um
because he's gay you know his family
doesn't accept him and you know like so
many families who are Uber religious and
think that that's wrong uh would just
chalk it up as you know the devil got a
hold of him or you know hopefully you
know well Mary Griffith did 180 and
realize she's the one who killed her son
not you know not her you know she pushed
her son to death right and instead of
continuing that style she does complete
180 and you know to this day she was one
of the leading activists for uh lgbtq
plus rights wow I mean it's just the
story in itself is mind-boggling and
talking to her about her son and her
interactions and that stuff is also
you're like it
the amount of respect I have for to
openly talk about that you know be like
you're telling me you killed your son
and she's like you know it's the worst
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life is to admit to admit that and
realize that I did that you know and
then she's like now from here on out I'm
trying to correct that it's a powerful
it's a powerful message so a movie like
that like trust me I would I would meet
people all the time and I still meet
them all the time who write me letters
and and be like you know you've changed
the way my parents talk to me or like
you meet like a giant it must be
military man giant Burly man comes up to
you and you're like let's come up and
shake my hand and be like I look at my
son differently because of you and
you're like what it's it's once and
again you have that stuff same thing
with Teen Wolf stuff but for me with
Teen Wolf you know the same sort of
thing we're like it's just a TV show
about werewolves but it does affect
people's lives or if you're going
through a bad time and you know you're
you're struggling to get out of bed you
find joy in a show that that you know
brings you laughter or you know keeps
you waking up the next day and just to
get you out of that funk you know it
means a lot to people and that and
that's the thing where you're like wow
this is bigger than just me acting and
uh and it's cool and that's the stuff
that really I enjoy that aspect I love
when people tell me things like that and
same sort of thing I've had experiences
where you know I met a girl who who
she's passed away since but uh Teen Wolf
was her favorite thing and she was
squirrels dying of cancer she was young
and she and again I was terrified I had
to go like in like a hazmat suit to even
talk with her uh I went there with some
of the casts and I was terrified I was
like I don't know if I can handle this
like I'm not good with death I don't
want to see a kid that's you know that
only has a week left to live like what
how am I supposed to be strong for this
child and then going in there was like
one of the most powerful things I've
ever experienced because she was
stronger than any one of us
you know like she would crack jokes
about her dying with her parent and be
like well I'm not worried about me I'm
worried about my parents you know like
just in her her her energy was insane
and so to do things like that is pretty
cool yeah I would go
so the Ronald McDonald House a lot and I
would have to walk out and go to the
bathroom and get you know my composure
because I would just feel it coming and
I'd go in there and I would just like
break down for like five minutes and
then kind of get it together because it
was just like there's nothing worse than
a child suffering there just isn't I I
can't I can't imagine anything worse
than that you know it's like
you know sometimes it takes looking at
someone and going wow you're never gonna
have a life
you're never gonna
meet a girl and have a you know maybe a
a guy have a family and travel and and
just nothing I mean you're gonna
everything it's so premature it's
strange financially that it puts on the
parent like every usually they're just
barely holding on it's tough It's it's
and it's everywhere I'm gonna cry right
now think about it yeah seriously yeah I
could too it's like it's yeah I
yeah
it's not for the faint of heart that's
for sure hey there folks it's Michael
Rosenbaum and boy have I got a huge
announcement for you this has been a
long time coming and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there